Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. It is day 27.
We're in Hebrews chapter 12 today, where it says, "Make every
effort to live in peace with everyone and to be holy, for without
holiness, no one will see the Lord." Wow.
Let's just pause and say, oh my. The stakes there are
sky high. No one will see the Lord without holiness.
And secondly, let's take a moment to remember that holiness is gifted to us at
the new birth.
God calls the Corinthian Christians saints, and boy, they were messed up.
They had real issues. They misunderstood some stuff.
But they had the holiness of Christ gifted to them in a
moment of
time. And that's why he calls them saints, holy ones.
So here we are. We're ready to see the Lord at the moment of
salvation.
But I want you to notice the word follow.
In Hebrews 12:14, in King James Version, it says,
"Follow peace." What does that imply?
Well, there are two things that we're to follow, peace with all men, and the
holiness without which no one will see the
Lord.
Peace isn't something that you achieve and then never need to
achieve again. Why is that? Well, because
peace is a moving target.
It's a relationship word, and relationships move. They shift.
They change. They grow. They're not static.
They're dynamic.
And so I have to follow peace, pursue peace
because it moves with the relationship.
Now, what about holiness?
Now, we've already discussed that holiness is granted,
gifted to us at the new birth. Paul calls the Corinthians saints.
He calls the Ephesians saints, the 1 Thessalonians Christians.
Those are holy people. So you have it as a
Christian. You're a "hagioi", a holy one.
And we've already discussed that holiness is a relationship with the
source of all holiness. Therefore, it's
entirely expected that he says we have to follow and
pursue holiness just like we pursue peace. Why?
Because holiness moves. It is progressive. It makes progress.
It's inherently dynamic because it's a relationship.
It shifts. It changes. It grows. It increases.
Let me give you an illustration. I love my wife more today than I did the
day we were married. But I loved her with my
whole heart then.
I've grown, and she's grown. I loved her with all of my heart on the day of our
marriage, but I love her more now.
Holiness, like that, is not static. It's dynamic.
It moves. We cannot just sit and soak and sour.
We have to follow and pursue holiness.
So what does that mean? Well, does it mean becoming more and more like a monk?
Does it mean learn to meditate on the sound of one hand clapping?
Does it mean that every year you can pray an average of five
minutes longer than you did last time?
Every year I'm 20% more humble than I was last year.
Here's what it means. Are you ready?
You ready for this? This is profound.
It means whatever the Bible says it means.
So if God says holiness means being made completely holy
after you've been initially made holy, well, then you need to follow after that.
If the Bible says that holiness means being
cleansed after you've been cleansed,
then you need to follow after that.
If the Bible says holiness means having a united
heart instead of a divided heart, like we talked about in Psalm 86,
well, then you need to follow that.
If the Bible says being holy means being filled and controlled by the
Holy Spirit, like Ephesians 5, then you need to follow that.
Whatever it takes, wherever it leads.
Now, let's pick up in verse 15. In verse 15, where it
says, "See to it that no one falls short of the grace of God and no
bitter root grows up to cause trouble and defile
many. Keep peace with others and holiness so that
no root will spring up and bear bitter, sinful fruit
in your life, your family, your church." Oh, please.
Please hear me. I've seen too many people live in bitterness
and unforgiveness and never go deep enough in holiness,
never follow it aggressively enough,
that they
wind up letting the self idle live too long, and it bears bitter
fruit in their churches, and their families, and their marriage, and the
world around them. Please
follow peace. Pursue peace with all men, and
follow holiness wherever it leads.
Don't think that holiness is just some static thing you received when you got
saved, and now check that box. No. It's a relationship.
You can love God with all your heart, but you've got to keep moving on because your
heart keeps moving, and God keeps moving, too.
You got to keep following holiness,
without which no one will see the Lord. You got to follow.
So there's your metaphor for today, chasing after, pursuing this holiness
that is a growing relationship with the God that you may love with all of your
heart as best you know at the beginning.
But you got to keep growing in that and keep chasing it because you grow,
and he increases in his revelation of himself to you.
God bless you. I'll talk to you tomorrow.